don't tell me about Christmas I  understand Christmas I have been a  senator for a long time  isn't there anyone who knows what  Christmas is all about true Charlie  Brown I can tell you what Christmas is  all about let's get on with this  and there were in the same country  shepherds abiding in the field keeping  watch over their faces ridiculous for  unto you Is Born This Day in the City of  David a savior just Christ's glory are  you joking is this a joke that's what  Christmas is all about I don't know  anybody who thinks that except the  far-right wing of the Republican Party  almost home cookies the cookies that  taste almost homemade and peterpaul  Cadbury maker of mounds almond joy York  and Cadbury chocolate bars have  sponsored the Joe Biden war on Christmas